72 millions d'euros d'investissement
cette année 430 jusqu'en 2020 le
département des Yvelines maintient ses
ambitions en faveur des 138 collèges
privés et publics du département pour
cette rentrée CIN établissements sont
encore en travaux c'est le cas notamment
du collège René Descartes à FONTEN le
Fleury fin du chantier prévu pour l'an
prochain nous considérons que
l'investissement dans le secteur des
collèges est absolument stratégique à la
fois pour les familles pour les enfants
mais aussi pour l'attractivité du
territoire et puis à côté de ces
dépenses très lourdes il y a bien
entendu un effort fait sur le numérique
des tablettes numériques 15 % des
collégiens ivelinois ont une tablette à
titre expérimental et puis leur sécurité
ou en partenariat avec l'État et la
région N et les maires nous allons
chercher des solutions sécurité
numérique restauration scolaire les
priorités sont nombreuses cette année un
volet insertion est également mise en
place avec le recrutement de 228
bénéficiaires du RSA on a 1100 agent
dans dans nos collèges et une grande
partie pas une grande partie mais bon
c'est quand même du personnel qui fait
des tâches un petit peu difficiles ils
sont arrêtés de temps en temps pour des
problèmes de dos ou autres et on doit
palier à leur remplacement donc on a eu
l'idée donc de pouvoir mettre en place
directement dans nos établissements des
personnes qui sont bénéficiaires du RSA
donc et les mettre en situation d'emploi
donc ils sont là en plus pour pallier
éventuellement l'absence de de personnel
euh de agent d'entretien agent de
restauration agent d'accueil la
construction d'un collège innovant a
également été évoquée celui-ci verra le
jour en 2019 dans le quartier du
valfouré à mont-elajolie et permettra le
développement d'une nouvelle méthode
pédagogique axée notamment sur le
travail en
groupe